[Música]
josé vázquez 55 años bolivia
jose con 45 años por ella
se imaginan que yo puedo reconocer cada
zapato que hace cada uno de mis
artesanos en el taller
en todo este tiempo he aprendido mucho
de ellos y ellos me han enseñado
este es mi equipo de trabajo les
presento a mis zapateros nosotros
hacemos los zapatos a mano y nosotros
definitivamente hacemos arte en el
taller
en bonilla se produce en 13.5 millones
de zapatos a las máximas
70 pares al día por taller en el taller
nosotros producimos únicamente 6 pares
utilizando 4 máquinas
una máquina de coser
una devastadora en la pulidora
y nuestra herramienta indispensable
nuestras manos
hemos recuperado un antiguo oficio para
demostrarle a nuestro país y al mundo lo
que podemos hacer en artesanía
y este es el resultado
en siete meses que estamos produciendo
en el taller hemos logrado hacer 220
paredes para tomar cada uno de estos
mejora la anterior cada uno es cada vez
más perfecto
en este preciso momento puedo decir que
podemos competir a nivel internacional
con cualquier país porque estamos
haciendo las cosas correctamente estamos
haciendo calidad comodidad y diseño en
un país donde esto que hizo estaba
olvidado
seguramente ustedes se preguntan cómo he
llegado a este google y la verdad
bienvenido a contarles un poco de
misterio
yo seguí la línea tradicional de la
educación fui al colegio de la
universidad conseguir un trabajo estable
y se un diplomado y finalmente había
decidido ser una maestría pero antes de
comenzar y maestría tuve un punto de
quiebre donde realmente nada de lo que
hacían parecía ser muy feliz toda la
felicidad padecía momentánea
y realmente no me puse a pensar que yo
no estaba viviendo la vida solamente
estado arriba
entonces me hice dos preguntas la
primera pregunta fue qué está pasando
porque y la segunda pregunta fue que
quiero
la primera pregunta evidentemente la
respondía el segundo estaba en la zona
de confort y pues yo no pertenecía ahí
la segunda pregunta fue en el que quiero
el que quiero demoró aproximadamente
meses en aparecer porque hay muchas
cosas que uno se pone a pensar la
sociedad de nuestra gente de nuestro
nuestro mismo ambiente nos dice qué
cosas tenemos que querer y estas eran
las cosas que todos tenían que querer
entonces un día de esos
sentaban tuve como un golpe de verdad y
hasta ahorita siento como llegó ese
golpe a mí y branding te ha sido como un
escalofrío
y la verdad era una la revelación edad
misma no quería hacer zapatos y punto no
quería hacer nada más que zapatos y
porque todo el mundo se puede preguntar
el porqué definitivamente alguien puede
inclinarse directamente de ser una
persona que ha tenido una formación tan
profesional a una artesanía y la verdad
es que creo que es un tema de gusto es
algo que te llama y definitivamente es
algo que pese a cualquier cosa yo quería
sacarme la espina del tiempo me ha
pasado
entonces después de haber definido creo
quería hacer zapatos hubieron cuatro
momentos críticos el primero era la
confrontación para hacer realidad mi
sueño y para hacer lo material yo tenía
que realmente cree que yo quería hacer
zapatos y para eso tenía que decírselo
al mundo
el segundo punto fue la acción acción de
que de decir he tomado esta decisión
entonces voy a hacer lo que tenga que
hacer para conseguirlo entonces qué pasó
una pequeña historia llegó a mi casa
estaba listo para sentados tomando el té
y me siento y les digo papis han
renunciado mi trabajo todos que ha
pasado
perdón que me habían votado que había
pasado algo grave en el trabajo y la
verdad es que no porque ellos me dicen
pero porque si la maestría versiones en
seis meses
y ahí otra vez quiero hacer zapatos
todos se quedan callados y gracias a
dios tengo un apoyo y me dicen está bien
te apoyamos hazlo
siempre
saco de mi cartera el curso pagado el
pasaje y el alojamiento del país donde
me iba a ir y les digo la próxima semana
este ha sido el momento de acción porque
el momento que uno decide algo pueden
pasar meses hasta que uno lo hace y de
ese mes se vuelve un año y de sms se
vuelven años y luego tú te quedas en lo
que estabas
el tercer punto fue el conflicto
ese momento fue más crítico que
cualquiera porque en cuanto yo llegué a
hacer mi curso me di cuenta que era un
curso de diseño teórico en papel y eso
no era lo que yo quería hacer yo quería
hacer zapatos y zapatos no los vas a
hacer en papel sentado entonces en toda
la frustración toda la rabia y decir
buccella que no venga a hacer esto y
todas las cosas pues aparece una persona
y me dice
yo tengo un taller y si tú quieres
puedes venir a hacer tus prácticas
sanitarias y aprender de los artesanos
obvio pero odio odio yo cuando donde a
qué hora y la chica me dice la única lo
único es que tú tienes que vivir y hacer
como ellos eso quiere decir entras a la
misma hora te vistes como ellos sufren
lo que sufren ellos y te vas a la misma
hora que ellos sino no hay trato
obviamente como todo el mundo piensa que
tan difícil puede ser
micro se imaginan lo difícil que puede
ser era llegar a un taller a trabajar
desde las siete y cuarto de la mañana
oliendo pegamentos ensuciándose con
polvillos lastimándose las manos con
herramientas y definitivamente yo no
podía hacer ningún zapato bien
han pasado aproximadamente unas tres
semanas hasta que uno de los zapateros
me ha dejado terminar una parte del
zapato
entre paréntesis lo más terrible del
taller llegar y ser la única mujer
menor y todos los señores tenían a
partir de 40 años porque es un antiguo
oficio antiguo entonces gracias a dios
ellos me han visto como tal vez una hija
y me ha comenzó a enseñar con mucho amor
todo el arte que ellos hacían en el
taller todos los días
después de seis meses de haber estado
encerrada en el taller con ellos era
otra persona definitivamente valoraba
otras cosas y ahí es donde viene el
punto 4 el punto más crítico la
conversión que yo he leído con un
objetivo este lugar que días atrás
zapatos quería hacer una marca quería
todas las cosas que una persona se puede
imaginar
pero he terminado enamorando mes del
proceso
he terminado enamorándome de lo que
estos artesanos hacían día a día con sus
manos
de todo el valor y la magia que existen
en las manos de un artesano
el momento que ustedes compran un zapato
que sea artesanal este zapato tiene una
historia tiene la historia del día de
certeza no tiene la pasión de ese
artesana tiene el amor de ese artesano
es por eso que yo me enamorado de hacer
zapato
porque he visto que venden de amarte
no era un zapato era un zapato artesanal
lo que me lleva
definitivamente a estar orgullosa el día
de hoy de que al fin estoy pudiendo
hacer zapatos a mano en mi país y en mi
propio taller
eso quiere decir que yo he cumplido una
pequeña parte de mi sueño sé que todavía
vienen muchas cosas pero realmente
cuando uno comienza poco a poco puede
ver cómo se va a ir desencadenando todas
las situaciones que solamente
yo les propongo ahora que mañana se
siente en un momento y se acuerden de
todas aquellas cosas que nos hacían
vibrar cuando eran más jóvenes aunque
los hacen vibrar ahora quién causa es
aquella que los apasionan
y si todavía tal vez les causa
algo de curiosidad
mi revelación como un que puede hacer
escapadas
cuál es la suya
[Aplausos]